when I was doing my first movie The only
thing I knew is I wanted a female editor
because I just felt a female editor
would be more nurturing to the movie and
to me in the beginning he really doesn't
guide me and that I put together what I
think he wants and pretty much we've
worked together so long I can judge what
he would want it was sort of like
Sally's job to kind of like you know
little by little convince me to bring it
down and bring it down and bring it down
finally we'd bring it down and bring it
down and then I kind of brought it too
far down and then he said we got to
bring him back out that's it no more no
more no more no more we do that for
eight months so intense I see him more
than my husband and sometimes I you know
get annoyed with her for not reading my
mind a hundred percent I mean all right
you know it's not good enough that she
reads it 80 of the time all right we
work very intensely together and it's
kind of amazing that we still like each
other if I was with my husband that long
I don't think I'd like him that much